[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute metern etwas aufgefallen und zwar
gibt es auf youtube für spezielle wie
immer extrem gut laufen und das sind
videos die sich um youtuber und geld
gehen weil natürlich sehr viele leute
märchen geschichten darüber hören ich
will sie zu verdienen und dann youtuber
zb entfernt hingehen und da natürlich
erzählen sie für die weniger als sie
tatsächlich verdienen deswegen machen
wir heute ein thema rund um youtuber und
finanzen oder youtuber und geld wird
über und einkaufsmärkte eingeblendet
wenn ich mir auf erfolg erfahrt ihr
immer als erstes wenn ich einfach ich
habe gesagt dass ich jetzt heute in
diesem video nicht explizit auf den cent
oder euro genau sagen möchte was ich
persönlich jetzt verdiene an sich bin
ich ein sehr offener mensch der schon
viele dinge erzählt die andere nicht
erzählen würden aber ich finde es ein
bisschen promi club zu sagen ja ich
verdiene so und so viel bla bla bla
auf dieses video geklickt und zu wissen
wie viel ich selbst verdienen das werde
ich heute zumindest nicht in euro genau
sagen ich werde vielleicht irgend
relation angeben das wollte ich noch
klarstellen nicht dass irgendeine
schauten stellen denkt also kleine big
aber jetzt viel spaß für videos alles
klar vielen dank für diese frage zum
thema geld und finanzen liebe habe ich
danke dir dafür dass oder genauer
erklärt das warum es in deiner frage
geht und der bezug zum thema finanzen
war wirklich sehr gute frage liebe salia
das echt eine sehr gute frage also mein
vater ist selbst unternehmer und
deswegen findet er das ganz gut das mag
noch nicht auch privat quasi
unternehmerisches machen hat selbständig
sind und gut 400 videos mit anderen
menschen produzieren irgendwie autos und
natur selbständigkeit und dadurch dass
der unternehmer ist kann das
nachvollziehen und der 58 gut aber ich
glaube meine eltern richtig krasse
bedenken dass ich das cool teil mache
also das würden wir glaube ich gar nicht
gerne sehen wenn ich jetzt sage ich
macht ein jahr pause machen oder youtube
holla die waldfee da wird sogar richtig
dampf gibt
ich glaube ich würde mich erstmal ein
bisschen wundern verbissen ungewohnt
weil ich momentan halt so jeden tag
immer über youtube nachdenke und
versuche jeden tag video für euch zu
machen doch irgendwie gut zu machen das
heißt ich bin eigentlich war die partie
damit beschäftigt gedanklich wenn
youtube vorbei ich werde natürlich auch
vorbei aber ich glaube ich würde gar
nicht viel mehr freizeit haben wollen
und rumgammeln wollen sondern ich würde
mir irgendwas anderes suchen was aus
richtung selbständigkeit geht weil es
einfach youtube mir gezeigt dass es
richtig geile dem ich so eine sache
haben die man richtig durchzieht und
wegen selbstständigkeit so für mich sehr
geil vielleicht nicht alle autos
herstellen sehr gute frage hast du schon
mal da ein youtube status benutzt um ein
weib um zu kriegen das ist echt sehr
heikle frage aber ich bin wer bereit ist
beantworten leute der einzige fall an
die ich mich erinnern kann da war ich
mal in berlin feiern in die
kulturbrauerei in berlin party aus
berlin kommt vielleicht kennt aber
irgendwann aus den vereinigten staaten
oder so nicht wahr wie gesundheitlich
nicht mehr so ganz gut dabei ich glaube
das muss für diese stelle nicht weiter
ausführen und dann habe ich mich
irgendwie irgendwas hinreißen lassen und
hab ich weiß ich bin youtube uploader da
war aber ansonsten ausgenommen dieses
eine mal wo ich schon was im tee hatte
ich mir das nicht passiert weil ich das
mega plum finden wird über die volkswahl
fleisch zusammen bäßler links annemarie
bedeutet das dass ich gar nicht mehr
denken viele leute natürlich auch mein
geld auch mein gott ich weiß nicht also
ich erzähle eigentlich nur meinen besten
freunden so was ich so auf youtube
überhaupt mache also generell gemacht
also in richtung product placement
irgendwelche anderen sachen epub
merchandise zum beispiel gezeigt dass
wissen eigentlich auch nur so meine
engsten freunde dem rest gegenüber
verschweige ich das natürlich weil es
die auch einfach nicht lang geht und
weil ich glaube dass ich die
informationen missbrauchen würde nicht
mal so ich hab halt zwei jahre lang
youtube gemacht ohne wirklichen fans zu
verdienen oder etwas zu verdienen also
15 euro im monat zwei jahre lang und ja
dann ging es halt irgendwann los wenn
jetzt heute andré so und so viel anhört
diese person nur diese zahl und weiß wie
lange ich ohne geld verdienen quasi das
abarbeiten müssen denken wenn du
die missgeburt finde meine freunde also
die fünf eigentlich ok ok liebe er sich
liebe grüße an euch ihr seid spitzen
kleine pizza also wenn man normalerweise
auf anderen kanälen auftaucht wird wenn
ich zum beispiel mit luca video mache
oder wenn ich mit opulenten video mache
dann kriegt man dafür kein geld da ist
einfach fahren februar in der regel wenn
man so was für unternehmen macht wie zum
beispiel auch die unitymedia kann ist
kein produktplatzierung aber ist auch um
die richtung und das ist dann auch eine
sehr gute frage wieweit könntest du
gehen oder gehört würdest du gehen um
neue abonnenten zu gewinnen nicht länger
schon verfolgen wissen dass ich ab und
zu mal bitten stärkere titel machen oder
bist du ein stärkeres am netz oder halt
ab und traten auf meinem fall darstelle
wie die von gestern
schaut euch an aber an sich habe ich
schon klare grenzen ich würde nicht
gegen gewisse personen hätten weil man
einfach selbst meine vergangenheit schon
passiert ist und haben möchte ich würde
nicht gegen gewisse minderheiten hetzen
und ich versuche immer nicht zu vermuten
dass auch nicht auf meine zuschauer
wirken soll also ich weiß ich habe
teilweise aus der junge zuschauer ich
treffe jetzt teilweise auf vier jahre
alt oder jung ja keine ahnung ich auch
und dann kann ich einfach nicht in einem
video kam ich mit der flasche bier
empfehlen oder sowas von vorbild also
ich denke schon über so was ja oder
sagen wie geil kiffen ist kein
nachlassen so die grenzen für mich wenn
ich mir selbst denkt okay damit bis zum
kraft schlechtes vorbild mussten
negativen einfluss dann mach es nicht
aber sowas geht gewinnt der kritiker
durch wirkende und das sind preismacht
und ich würde auch mit bibi aufnehmen
wenn das liest bitte menschen nicht
gänzlich abgeschlossen
am anfang war es halt einfach so ein
eindruck den man hatte davon dass
versucht youtube gemacht hat und max
youtube gemacht hat damals war geld noch
nicht so ein riesig großes thema das war
auch nicht egal aber ich habe einfach
gelingt die beiden jungs gemacht haben
und das will ich auch machen es hat
europa mit aufmerksamkeit zu tun weil
ich ein kleiner bisher mittelpunkt steht
mit der zeit ist natürlich wickelt und
dann wurde so was wie geld aufzunehmen
wichtiger natürlich war man auch auf
anderen wirklich ernst ist die
möglichkeit hat konnte was zu verdienen
auf youtube wie bap und ich bin auch so
ehrlich mit euch dass ich nicht sagen
macht es nur wirklich geliebt habe und
gekauft meine produkte ich habe euch so
lief übrigens leute animieren uhr gibt's
weniger werbeeinnahmen haben ja ich
glaub ich brauche für den januar eine
kreativpause hier zähle steuersystem hat
mir auch wichtig aber auch wichtig ist
zum beispiel sich vorzustellen okay ich
irgendein video hoch und machen dumme
witze oder so mit max und schauen dann
so viele leute wie einen ganzen fußball
scheint sind das ist soweit welchen der
mitte vom fußballstadion stellt das mal
vor und rede mit max man kein bruder
macht irgendwie scheiße mit dem und
50.000 leute stehen draußen herum und
schauen zu
das waren sind also
ok alles klar auch vielen dank für
diesen sehr wertvollen beitrag leute
wenn das der fall wäre würde ab
wahrscheinlich keine videos mehr machen
weil dann würde er wahrscheinlich noch
draufzahlen müssen dafür dass er
hochlädt like discs kommentare sind
vollkommen abhängig davon wie viel man
verdient mit einem video als mit den
reinen youtube werbeeinnahmen
wie hängen größtenteils nur von den
klicks ab und dann natürlich davon
welchem land das in amerika verlegen
mehr hatten deutsche aber likes und ist
vollkommen egal dafür jetzt klingelt an
der tür alles klar leute ist so schön so
gemütlich haben wir ihn so mit geilen
fragen versorgt auch für die info at t
spielt ok also hier nochmal die frage ob
like relevant für geld das ist wie
gesagt nicht der fall die einnahmen sind
vollkommen unabhängig davon wie viel
leid wird das exponat wahrscheinlich
fragen paar von euch weil immer an
youtube sagen sie hunderttausend lass
mal so viel leichter aber die sache ist
das machen die eigentlich nur um ihr
eigenes ego zu pushen
die videos funktionieren nicht besser
weil die mehrheit haben nur das machen
wir aber nur um fast 100 auf ein video
in kraft aber unter gewissen umständen
kann man auch verstehen
zum beispiel dass die perfekte frage um
dieses team zum thema finanzen
abzuschließen findet wird baby aussieht
wie ein pferd
da muss man eine themenspezifische
antwort natürlich jahr lauten wenn ihr
mal zweiten teil haben wollt dann
schaffen die kommentare hier könnte man
kanal abonnieren hier und in zufälliger
also video abchecken laster wenn ihr weg
geht und natürlich ein zweites ei und
leute ich hab ein